Prof: So we have begun
by talking about general
equilibrium,
and this was the background to
the course so that you're all
familiar.
Those of you who haven't taken
freshman economics or
intermediate economics,
what's the background that's
required for the course?
And the fact that general
equilibrium is a part of finance
is,
as I say, a bit of an
innovation because most finance
courses are taught entirely
independently of economic
theory.
But the two greatest Yale
economists and two greatest Yale
financial economists had finance
and economics integrated,
and I believe that's the only
right way of looking at the
problem.
And as I said at the very
beginning, I think the events of
the last few years have
confirmed that view.
So let's take up the question
today of why is the free market
supposedly so good.
So we worked out two examples
last time, and the two examples
are very similar to the first
problem set that you did.
In the first example you've got
two agents A and B,
and whenever we write agents A
and B we really mean a million
agents just like A and a million
agents just like B.
The heart of perfect
competition in the economy is
that there's lots of people,
and so we can't--yeah,
I think from now on hand them
in at the end of class.
So we mean a million people of
type A and a million people type
B.
So the utility function of A,
the welfare function of A is
written there,
and the welfare function of B
is written and they each begin
with endowments.
So when these two million
people come together they're
going to be doing the same thing
that you saw in the class on the
first day.
They're going to be haggling,
and arguing,
and the buyers are going to
always say "the stuff's not
worth very much and why should
they pay you so much,"
and the sellers are going to
say "it's worth a
tremendous amount and they
should pay even more,"
and eventually they're going to
come to prices.
And we discovered last time
that the way of describing what
prices and what final
allocations they come to is by
writing down a system of
equations,
and you did that all in your
homework and we came up with
this outcome.
So similarly we did another
problem in the last class and we
wrote down different welfare
functions or utility functions
and different endowments and
again we got the equilibrium.
So we said that one of the
amazing things is that these
system of equations,
the six equations for each
economy that you solved in class
always have a solution.
So the people who discovered
that discovered it at the Cowles
Foundation.
They were Ken Arrow,
Gerard Debreu who was a Yale
assistant professor,
Ken Arrow who was visiting the
Cowles Foundation in Chicago but
was a Stanford professor,
and Lionel McKenzie who
actually taught at Rochester.
The economic equations always
have a solution.
So what's so good about that
economic solution?
Adam Smith talked about the
invisible hand,
but there was no mathematics in
Adam Smith.
So why do we think equilibrium
is such a good thing?
After all, you saw in the
example that there were three
pairs of people who forlornly
couldn't trade at all.
So clearly not everybody gets
to trade, discrimination
happens.
Some people get the stuff.
Other people don't get the
stuff.
Well, the first approach of
economists was that equilibrium
maximizes the sum of utilities.
So let's see how that works in
this example.
So this example's very special
because everybody thinks that
the good Y has constant marginal
utility of 1.
So that's going to play a big
role in our optimization in
maximizing the sum of utility.
So if you want to maximize the
sum of utilities you have to
maximize (100X^(A) -
碼^(A) squared) (30X^(B)
- 碼^(B) squared) (Y^(A)
Y^(B)) such that X^(A) X^(B) =
84 which is the sum of 4 and 80
and Y^(A) Y^(B) = 6,000.
So the claim is that if all
these two million people meet in
a room like this and start
shouting at each other,
and trading and offering deals
and stuff,
it's going to come down to a
final allocation which we've
written over there were A gets
77 of the first good and B gets
7 of the first good,
and that final allocation is
going to maximize the sum of
utilities.
So why should that be the case?
In fact in this example it is
the case.
Well why is it the case?
Because there's constant
marginal utility of Y,
so we don't have to worry about
the Y allocation at all because
if you increase Y^(A) and
decrease Y^(B) they still have
to add up to 6,000.
You're going to be lowering A's
utility and raising B's utility
by the same amount so you won't
have changed the sum of
utilities.
So the Y's are totally
irrelevant to this maximizing
the sum of utilities.
So all we have to do is make
sure that the X allocation,
maximize the sum of utilities
for the good X.
So that you can see must be the
case because we have to maximize
the sum of two people's
utilities or two million
utilities.
You can always plug in X^(B) as
a function of X^(A),
namely 84 [clarification:
X^(B) = 84 - X^(A)].
So let's write it as a function
of X^(A),
and we can replace this
maximization by recognizing that
X^(B) is just a function of
X^(A).
In fact, it's a very special
function where the derivative of
X^(B) with respect to X^(A)--
so let's call the function,
we'll call it that to denote
that it's a function--
happens to equal -1.
So we want to maximize this
over X^(A) taking into account
that X^(B) is just a function of
X^(A),
because to maximize you have to
keep feasible.
So we've now ignored all the
constraints.
Constraints have now
disappeared provided we keep
track of the fact that X^(B) is
a function of X^(A).
So why is it the case that the
equilibrium 77 and 7 maximizes
this?
Well, the key is diminishing
marginal utility.
We know that the utility
function for--
here's X--utility function for
A is quadratic so it looks
something like that,
and the utility function for B
also looks something like that.
And so if you look at this
function entirely as a function
of A it's also going to look
like that.
So by diminishing marginal
utility, the function,
the sum of utilities is
concave.
Concave, remember,
is a picture like that.
So what is the essence of a
picture like that?
It means that setting
derivative equal to zero implies
you are at max.
So that's not true of any
function.
If you have a function like
that and then it goes up like
that you could have the
derivative of zero here and not
really be at the max,
but because there's diminishing
marginal utility more and more
of X does less and less good so
it turns down.
So all you have to do is figure
out that the derivative is zero,
which it is at this point,
and then you know you're at the
maximum.
But that at X^(A) = 77 has to
be the case because if you plug
in X^(A) = 77 and you take the
derivative of all this with
respect to X^(A) of this whole
thing,
taking into account as before
that X^(B) is a function of
X^(A),
you just get (100 - X^(A)) now
it's just going to be (30 -
X^(B)) times the derivative of
X^(B) with respect to X^(A).
Why is that?
Because you know the chain
rule, if I differentiate
everything with respect to X^(A)
and X^(B) is a function of X^(A)
it's just 30 because I'm taking
the derivative with respect to
X^(B).
So it's 30 times the derivative
of X^(B) with respect to X^(A)
minus the derivative with
respect to X^(B) is X^(B) times
the derivative of X^(B) with
respect to X^(A),
so it's that.
But if you plug in X^(A) = 77
and X^(B) = 7,
DX^(B), DX^(A) is -1 you just
get 23 - 23 = 0,
because the marginal utility of
A is equal to the marginal
utility of B at equilibrium.
The sum of utilities is
maximized, and that's the end of
the story.
So that you noticed in the
problem set, something like
that.
You may not have given exactly
this argument.
That's what you were supposed
to have sort of discovered in
doing the problem set and now
we've confirmed what you already
pretty much knew.
So are there any questions
about that?
It's just the simple
generalization of our football
ticket example where the
football tickets end up in the
hands of the people who want
them the most,
and A happens to like a lot of
tickets,
not just one,
and so A's going to keep buying
tickets until he's bought 77 of
them.
And by then the next football
ticket is worth less than 23 to
him.
B, she likes football tickets a
little less.
She's not going to buy as many.
By the time she gets down to 7
football tickets she's going to
think--so she hasn't bought
nearly as many.
When she's gotten to 7 football
tickets she's going to think the
next one's worth less than 23.
And since the price is 23
they're going to both stop
there,
but they're each going to stop
at the same point where the last
ticket is worth the same to each
of them,
and all the previous football
tickets each bought is worth
more to each of them.
So there's no way of
rearranging the tickets because
if you did you'd have to take a
football ticket that was worth
more than 23 from one of them
and give that ticket to the
other one who by then would
think it was worth less than 23.
So that's the argument.
Okay.
So economists were beside
themselves with their brilliance
in having proved this theorem
and given a mathematical form to
the invisible hand.
Whenever you take a verbal
argument like Adam Smith and
turn it into a mathematical
argument you've understood it
better.
You understand why it's true
and you also start to understand
why in some circumstances it
might not be true.
So for 50 years,
let's say between 30 and 50
years this was the fundamental
argument of economics and
economic equilibrium that
equilibrium was a good thing
because it maximized the sum of
utilities.
But then little by little,
starting with Irving Fisher and
a bunch of people at the same
time and a little bit later,
so Hicks and Samuelson are
famous for this,
they began to wonder what kind
of crazy utility functions are
these where there's some
mysterious good that has
constant marginal utility of 1.
So in modern terms how could
you justify it?
You could say,
"Well, maybe there's a
machine where we can calibrate
exactly how happy people are and
we can measure it.
So for example,
we can measure how aroused
their skin is.
The skin texture changes as you
become less and more aroused.
Maybe we could measure that.
With MRIs we can measure brain
waves.
Maybe you can calibrate how
many brain waves are spinning
around and how happy somebody
is,
and maybe there's some
mysterious good like food that
has constant marginal
utility."
Well, that doesn't seem very
persuasive to me and it wasn't
to the economists of the
beginning of the twentieth
century.
They all argued,
starting with Irving Fisher,
that it made no sense to think
that we could actually measure
utility,
and more than that it made even
less sense there'd be some good
that had constant marginal
utility of 1.
So Fisher put everything on a
symmetric footing and said,
"Let's think of the two
goods, X and Y,
as more or less symmetric.
I mean, there's no reason why
one has to have some special
role."
So let's look at this
equilibrium which we got the
same way, and you did this on a
problem set solving for
equilibrium.
Does this maximize the sum of
utilities?
Well, the answer is if it did
maximize the sum of utilities at
the final allocation we couldn't
gain anything by switching,
reducing 9 fifths a little bit
and increasing 6 fifths a little
bit.
But what is the sum of
utilities?
So if you write W^(A) W^(B)
it's going to be for one thing
(3 fourths log X^(A)) (2 thirds
log X^(B)).
So let's look at the marginal
utility to X^(A)--of good A.
That's 3 fourths,
so marginal utility of A,X
marginal utility of B,X = 3
fourths times 1 over 9 fifths
which is 5 ninths.
That equals 15 over 36,
which is 5 over 18 if I've done
that right.
It doesn't sound right.
Student: It's 5 over 12.
Prof: 5 over 12.
Thank you.
That sounds better.
But let's look at--so this is
the margin utility of X^(A) is 5
twelfths.
What's the marginal utility to
B of X?
Well, it equals 2 thirds times
1 over 6 fifths,
which is 5 sixths,
which is 10 over 18,
which is 5 over 9.
So these two numbers are
different.
The marginal utility to B is
bigger than the margin
utility--of X--is bigger than
the margin utility to A of X.
So clearly the final
equilibrium allocation doesn't
maximize the sum of utilities.
By switching some goods from A
to B you could make both people
better off [clarification:
you could increase the sum of
both peoples' utilities,
though one person would end up
worse off in the process].
So that was a shock to
economists.
It meant that the argument
they'd relied on,
the thing which they were using
to persuade policy people that
the free markets were a good
thing,
is a false argument.
It rests on a premise that's
indefensible,
namely that there's constant
marginal utility and everybody
can measure it.
So they needed some other
definition, some other way of
capturing the mathematical idea
that the invisible hand is a
good thing.
And the reason I'm spending so
much time emphasizing this,
even though you've seen this
before,
is because if economists made a
mistake once what makes you
think they haven't made another
mistake?
So now let's give the argument
that in a weaker sense the
invisible hand holds,
that is that the free market
comes to a very socially
desirable equilibrium.
And later in the course we're
going to find that that argument
is also too narrow.
So my point that I'm going to
gradually get to is that
economists have constantly taken
too narrow and too special a
view of the world,
and as you enlarge the view of
the world you have,
not by making things
mathematically simpler,
actually you have to make them
mathematically slightly more
complicated,
as you enlarge the view of the
world you have you get closer to
the truth and you start to find
that the free market isn't quite
as wonderful as you thought at
first and therefore there's room
for government regulation.
So it's not,
as Paul Krugman argued,
that economists are transfixed
by mathematics and seduced into
simple conclusions that the free
market is perfect.
On the contrary I would say
they were afraid of too much
mathematics,
and by looking too narrowly
they didn't realize what they
could have just by being
mathematically more
sophisticated.
So it's a failure of
sophistication,
not too much sophistication.
So what did the economists
argue?
So the chief among them,
Hicks, Samuelson,
Pareto and Fisher,
all these people basically came
to the same conclusion.
They said, "Well,
it makes no sense to talk about
the sum of utilities."
Let's talk about Pareto
Efficiency.
So what's the general problem?
The general problem is you
start with an economy made up of
all these individuals.
Let's call them W^(A) and
W^(B),
but it could be as many as we
want so let's just say W^(i)--
and E^(i), so E^(i) is the
endowment of X and E^(i) of Y.
So that's the economy.
You start from the economy and
you go to equilibrium.
And equilibrium is a price
vector P_X
P_Y and allocations
X^(i),
Y^(i), i in I,
such that summation over all
the i's of X^(i) equals the
summation for all the i's of
E^(i)_X.
So i's final consumption of X,
plus j's final consumption of
X,
plus everybody else's final
consumption of X,
those are the sum of the
X^(i)'s,
is equal to the sum of
everybody's endowment.
And similarly for the Y's,
[equals the sum]
of E^(i)_Y and such
that everybody is doing what's
in their personal interest which
is maximizing W^(i) of X,
Y, so, the max of W^(i) of X,
Y such that [(P_X
times X) (P_Y times
Y)]
= [(P_X times
E^(i)_X)
(P_Y times
E^(i)_Y)]
is solved by X^(i),
Y^(i) for all i.
That's the definition of
equilibrium.
Everybody individually
optimizes looking at his own
budget set,
the hell with everybody else,
does the best in his interest,
chooses X^(i),
Y^(i) at the going prices,
supply equals demand,
that's how you get the final
allocation.
So that's the definition of
equilibrium and now we're trying
to argue that's a good thing.
So what's our criterion?
Well, what Pareto and Edgeworth
and everybody else decided is,
"Let's look at the welfare
functions W^(A) and W^(B)."
So if you take some allocation
like the original allocation 2-1
and 1-2 you'll have a welfare of
each person,
(3 fourths log 2) (one quarter
log 1) that's the welfare of A,
and the welfare of B will be (2
thirds log 1) (1 third log 2),
so that'll be some point here.
So this is welfare B,
welfare A at initial endowment.
And then if you look at the
welfare at the final allocation,
so, (3 fourths log 9 fifths) (1
quarter log 3 halves) you know
it's going to be something like
this.
It's got to be up here.
It's going to be better for
both people.
How do you know that?
Because A had the choice of
just buying his initial
endowment--that's always
affordable and he chose not to
do it.
He chose to do something else
and he was better off and the
same with B,
so clearly the equilibrium
allocation is going to be better
than the initial endowment.
And so the Pareto criterion is
that an allocation X^(i)-hat,
Y^(i)-hat, Pareto dominates an
allocation--
so this is for all I--X^(i),
let's put the i's on the top.
If and only if everybody's
better off: W^(i) (X^(i)-hat,
Y^(i)-hat) is bigger than
W^(i)(X^(i), Y^(i)).
So we started with an
allocation, the E allocation
here, and then we moved to
competitive equilibrium here and
everybody was better off.
So the equilibrium allocation
Pareto dominates the initial
allocation.
But now the question is maybe
there's some other allocation
besides the competitive
equilibrium allocation that
dominates the equilibrium
allocation.
So the theorem is that if P,
(X^(i) Y^(i)),
i in I is an equilibrium for
the economy E--
remember we defined the economy
E, I better put E here--
then no allocation (X^(i)-hat,
Y^(i)-hat), i in I,
Pareto dominates (X^(i),
Y^(i)) if summation X^(i)-hat
equals summation
E^(i)_X and
summation--
got a little too tight here,
sorry about this,
Y^(i)-hat equals,
this is over i,
equals summation
E^(i)_Y.
So I can read this,
it's really bad.
It's a critical line right in
the corner.
So I'll just say it in words
and then read it literally.
So this allocation dominates
this one.
The competitive equilibrium
dominated the initial endowment,
but maybe there's some other
way of rearranging the goods
that gets you even further out
here.
The theorem says that's
impossible.
So it says if you start with a
competitive equilibrium,
with an allocation (X^(i),
Y^(i)) for the economy E,
the no allocation like that
one, no allocation (X^(i)-hat,
Y^(i)-hat) can Pareto dominate
it.
This couldn't happen.
You'd have to be down here
somewhere.
That couldn't happen provided
this other allocation used up
the resources that were
available.
So the sum of the X's in this
allocation is the sum of the
initial endowments,
and the sum of the Y's in this
allocation is the sum of the
initial endowments over the
people.
So of course if you add more
goods to the economy you can
make everybody better off,
but using the existing goods in
the economy,
which is the sum of the
E^(i)_X's and the sum
of the E^(i)_Y's,
there's no way to make everyone
better off than at the
competitive equilibrium.
So it says literally if P
(X^(i), Y^(i)) is an equilibrium
for the economy E,
which is that,
which includes the initial
endowments,
the no allocation (X^(i)-hat,
Y^(i)-hat) Pareto dominates
(X^(I),
Y^(I)) if the sum over I of
X^(i)-hat equals the sum over i
of E^(i)_X,
and if the sum of the
Y^(i)-hats over i equals the sum
of the E^(i)_Y's.
That's the theorem.
So we've totally weakened the
definition of equilibrium.
So it might be that if this is
the competitive allocation if
you look at this line this is
same sum of utilities,
because if this slope is -1 and
here's the utility to B and the
utility to A everything on this
line has the same utility.
So that theorem would say
anything else that's feasible
had to be down here.
The sum is less than that.
But here we're not saying that.
We're no longer saying that.
Maybe you can increase the sum.
From this equilibrium you could
increase the sum by taking
something away from A and giving
it to B.
You could increase the sum.
So that would have been here.
You increase the sum,
so you no longer have maximized
the sum,
but the fact is to make B
better off you had to make A
worse off and that's the new
criterion,
Pareto Efficiency.
So that's the theorem and now
we're going to prove it so that
you can see the whole logic of
the free market just amounts to
that.
So are there any questions
about this?
You all supposedly saw this
before, but that doesn't mean
you really did.
So does anyone have a question
what's going on?
This is a very basic incredibly
important idea.
All right, so I'll give you one
more chance.
Somebody must have a question.
Yes?
Student: Could you just
re-say the theorem a little bit
more slowly?
Prof: Yes.
Why don't I draw a picture,
which is what I was going to do
anyway?
So let's draw a picture,
and I'll bring the theorem back
after having drawn the picture.
So the picture is going to be
due to Edgeworth.
So he invented the indifference
curve and he invented it in
order to draw this picture.
It was an incredibly clever
picture.
So he says, "Let's look at
this economy,"
the one on the right that we
start with.
We put X^(A) here and X^(B)
here and you notice that A
begins with an endowment of
(2,1).
So let's put his endowment
(2,1) here.
So this is E^(A)_X =
2 and this is E^(A)_Y
= 1, right?
That makes sense.
Now we can draw his
indifference curves through
that.
So his indifference curves he
likes X more than he likes Y,
so the indifference curves are
going to be sort of vertical.
He doesn't like to give up X
very much, so his indifference
curves are going to look sort of
like this.
And the most important
indifferent curves are the ones
where he gets better off than he
was before.
So now in the end there's going
to be a budget set which is X is
way more expensive than Y,
so there's going to be a budget
set that looked like this.
That's sort of the budget set
that he faces.
And he's not going to choose
this.
It turns out he chooses
something like here which is he
chooses a little bit less of X,
9 fifths, and a little bit more
of Y.
So here's X^(A) = 9 fifths
which is a little less than 2,
and X^(B) he chose was,
I can't read it,
3 halves which is more than 1.
Are you with me?
You asked the question.
Does this picture make sense?
Student: Yes.
Prof: So he obviously
did better than he did before,
but we've got another guy to
worry about.
So how can you put the second
guy in the same diagram?
Well, let's just add the total
endowment.
Where's the total endowment?
Well, it's 3 units of each.
So here we've got 2.
So this is 1,2, this must be 3.
So the total endowment of good
X is 3,2 1 is 3 and a good Y is
3 as well.
Here's 1, here's 2, here's 3.
This is supposed to be a square.
The aggregate endowment is here.
This is the total endowment,
3 of each.
What are the feasible
allocations?
So this is an extremely clever
insight of Edgeworth's.
He said, "Look,
the total endowment is (3,3).
If I tell you that A has got
(2,1) (that's this point) what's
left over, B must be
consuming."
So B's consuming the distance
from here to here which is
obviously (1,2).
And if A ends up over here at 9
fifths,
3 halves, that's from here to
here is 9 fifths and 3 halves,
since the total is (3,3) B's
obviously consuming what's left
over,
so he's consuming this
difference.
So whatever A does you can see
in the diagram looking at it the
normal way,
but if you just sort of twist
your mind a little bit and look
from this direction,
once you know what A's doing
you can figure out what B's
doing,
so each of these points defines
a feasible allocation.
And now what we want to say,
the theorem says,
look at the utilities that A
and B got out of this
allocation.
A is on this indifference curve.
You know what he's doing.
B you know is coming from here.
We know how he's doing.
So look at the allocation they
got.
You can't make both people
better off than that by choosing
some other point in this square.
So let's look at it from B's
point of view.
From B's point of view B likes
more of everything.
So if A gets less B's going to
get more.
So from B's point of view the
further out you go this way the
better it is for B.
So the axes for B looks like
that.
So he's going to have some
indifference curve that--B's
indifference curve has to look
like this.
So here's where B started here,
and then B's going to be better
off doing like this.
So B's indifference curve looks
something like that.
Those are B's indifference
curves.
So the further out you go this
way the better off B is,
so as you shrink what A gets,
that obviously means B's
getting more,
and so B's getting happier and
happier.
So what is the definition of
Pareto Efficiency?
Whatever point we pick like
this one to begin with:
is there a way of making both
people better off.
Well the answer is the
competitive equilibrium makes
both people better off.
Why is that?
If you can see it from back
there, the reason is that A went
from this white indifference
curve to a better indifference
curve over here.
B, whose budget line is the
same budget line looked at from
his point of view,
he went from his indifference
curve over here to one here.
So he went from this yellow
indifference curve to a better
one, so both of them got better
off going to this final
allocation than they started
with.
And of course that had to be
true because A could always have
chosen to stay where he was at
(2,1).
He moved to (9 fifths,
3 halves) because it was
better, and B could have stayed
where she was at (1,2).
She chose to go to (6 fifths,
3 halves) because it made her
better off,
so both of them must be better
off at the final allocation than
they were to begin with.
What does the theorem say?
The theorem says--remember,
in pictures,
it says whatever point we pick
here that defines something for
A and defines something for B,
then we can look at the utility
welfare functions of both and
see what indifference curves
they're on.
The theorem says there's no
other point in this whole
diagram which puts both A and B
on a higher indifference curve
for each of them than they were
at the competitive equilibrium.
So if I read the definition
again it says,
if I start with an economy
there with the endowments and
the utility functions,
so the endowments and the
indifference curves,
and I compute the competitive
equilibrium like we did over
there,
then no allocation,
that means no point in that box
could make everybody better off
than they were at the
competitive equilibrium provided
that new point is in the box.
So it makes the sum of the X's
equal to the sum of the
endowments, and the sum of the
Y's equal to the sum of the
endowments of Y.
This is the end of the proof.
We already gave the proof
according to Edgeworth.
So what's the proof according
to Edgeworth?
He says, "It's all a
matter of looking at it the
right way."
It's easy to look at the
picture from A's point of view.
You just look at the X-axis and
the Y-axis.
This is the Y-axis.
What is this?
This is X^(A)_Y.
It was 3 halves.
So this is the Y-axis going
this way.
This is the Y-axis and this is
the X-axis going this way.
For A it's very simple to look
at the Y-axis and the X-axis for
A.
A's got its indifference curve
getting better and better.
So from A's point of view it's
very simple,
you look at the endowment,
you draw the budget line
through it,
which is some linear line,
and then A picks the best point
on that budget set drawing the
tangent,
which is the white indifference
curve to this point right here.
That's the best he can do.
Now the trick is to see that
from B's point of view up here
things look very similar because
B's endowment is also at this
point.
He's got 1 unit up here of X
and 2 units of Y.
Why does he have that?
Because the two together added
up to 3, so if this is what A's
endowment was then of course
what's left over is B's
endowment.
So B has to go here.
Now what does the budget set
look like for B?
Well it's also a linear thing
with the same slope and it goes
through this point.
So from his point of view this
pink line is also his budget
set.
It goes from here all the way
down to where it hits his Y-axis
down here.
They've got the same budget set
just looked at from opposite
sides.
Now what is competitive
equilibrium and supply equals
demand mean?
It means that when A chooses
this point as the best point,
which happened to have been (9
fifths,
3 halves), then B is happy to
choose what's left over as his
best point.
So his optimal point,
his indifference curve that's
tangent to his budget set has to
be the same point looked at from
his origin instead of A's
origin.
That's the trick.
So that's the key insight that
Edgeworth had,
his beautiful picture,
and now the point is that if
the white indifference curve
looks like that,
anything that makes A better
off has to be on this side of
the white indifference curve and
the yellow indifference curve,
which is B's indifference
curve, anything that makes her
better off has to be on this
side of the yellow curve,
but the white curve goes that
way and the yellow curve goes
that way.
So there's no point that's
simultaneously above A's
indifference curve and also
above B's indifference curve.
So therefore nothing could
Pareto dominate it.
So that's the Edgeworth proof.
Yes?
Student: So no matter
what our point's going to be on
our pink budget line because
that's >
down.
That's all the goods we have.
Prof: Right.
The pink budget line describes
what you can afford to buy,
describes the budget equation,
this equation,
so everyone's going to choose
on the pink line.
This point is feasible.
B gets almost nothing and A
gets almost everything.
B's never going to let himself
be forced down there because B
can choose something on the pink
line,
so he's always going to choose
something better than that.
So that's proof number one.
I'm just going to give proof
number two.
Most of you have seen this
before, but I'm going to give
another proof and then I'm going
to see whether you really
understand what all this means.
So here's a second proof.
This is a much better proof.
I'm going to write this
algebraically.
The proof of Arrow 1951 and
Debreu 1951 separately,
so this is called the
Fundamental Theorem of
Economics, First Welfare Theorem
of Economics.
So all this pictorial stuff
makes so many assumptions,
there are only two kinds of
traders, there are only two
goods.
They are consuming only on the
boundaries.
I mean, they're never consuming
on the boundaries it's always in
this,
you know, there are just so
many special assumptions and
everything is two by two.
It's just special case.
So let's give a much more
general proof of this theorem.
So here we've got--two goods
won't play any role.
There could be any number of
goods.
There are two goods only here,
but there are many traders,
lots and lots of traders.
So, what's the proof that
(X^(i) hat, Y^(i) hat) couldn't
Pareto dominate it?
So supposed that we've
got--this is equal to summation
X^(i)-hat, and this is equal to
summation Y^(i)-hat.
So we've got another allocation
which is feasible.
So could it be that this other
feasible allocations of
X^(i)-hat's and Y^(i)-hats,
could that make everybody
better off?
Could that make each i better
off than (X^(i),
Y^(i))?
And this proof is so short and
so beautiful,
so elegant, and so convincing
that it's mesmerized people now
for over 50 years and it
prevents them from seeing that
there could be an even a more
general situations where things
aren't so great.
So what is the proof?
It's two lines.
If (X^(i)-hat,
Y^(i)-hat) is really better for
i, then I claim--line one,
W^(i) of (X^(i)-hat,
Y^(i)-hat).
Sorry, this is line zero.
This is just repeating what's
the case.
W^(i) of X^(i)-hat,
Y^(i)-hat greater than
W^(i)(X^(i), Y^(i)).
That's for all i.
That's the claim.
Could this happen that you've
got a feasible (X^(i)-hat,
Y^(i)-hat) and it makes
everybody better off than
(X^(i), Y^(i)).
Could this happen?
The answer's no.
Line one is,
if that were true then it would
have to be the case that
P_X times X^(i)-hat
P_Y times Y^(i)-hat
had to be greater than
P_X times
E^(i)_X P_Y
times E^(i)_Y.
Why is that?
Because the budget set of Mr.
i says he spends all his money
on X and Y in his budget set and
does the best he can.
(X^(i), Y^(i)) solves this
problem.
So if this thing really makes
him better off than what he
chose, it can't be that it was
affordable--otherwise he would
have bought this instead.
So it has to be that for i,
this bundle cost more than he
can afford.
That's why he didn't choose it.
So this relies on agent
rationality.
Everybody given his choices,
he doesn't care about the rest
of the world,
but given his choice
everybody's doing the best thing
he can.
Shiller would say,
"People make mistakes.
They're crazy.
They have no idea what they're
doing.
They're stupid.
Some guy tells them a story in
the bar one night and they
totally change their life
around,"
so he'd say all this isn't
true.
All right, but anyway I
actually believe that people
have more sense about deciding
for themselves what's good for
them than third parties do about
deciding what's good for them.
So I don't want to challenge
this.
So if you don't challenge this
you conclude that if something
makes everybody better off each
person must have found this
allocation unaffordable
otherwise he would have chosen
it.
[Audio dropped]
over i of E^(i)_Y.
So all I did was--that's true
for every single person i.
So I could add this inequality
for i,
plus this inequality for j,
plus this inequality for all
the people and then I use the
distributive law to take the sum
inside and I have this.
But that is impossible and
that's the end of the proof
because the sum of this
X^(i)-hat is equal to this sum.
That was what we had supposed.
You're just rearranging all the
goods that are really there and
this sum is the same as this
sum.
So therefore since the new
allocation just rearranges the
endowment differently from the
equilibrium,
and rearranges the X's maybe
differently from the
equilibrium,
it has to be that actually this
thing on the left is equal to
this thing on the right.
It's identical to it so it
can't be greater and that's the
contradiction.
That's the end of the proof.
So it's two lines,
two lines to prove what Adam
Smith spent 400 pages arguing
that the free market is a good
thing.
So this is the basis for the
idea that we shouldn't regulate,
we shouldn't regulate,
we shouldn't regulate.
Sounds pretty convincing,
so any questions about this?
Anything you'd like to say?
Are you convinced by this?
What are some reasons you don't
believe this,
some obvious reasons?
Yes?
Student: Well,
even if this proof makes sense
a lot of regulation policies
have to do with changing the
prices of things anyway so we're
not necessarily
>
with them at market
Prof: I'm glad you asked
that question because it betrays
a misunderstanding,
so I'm glad you asked that
question.
So this theorem is correct
given the assumptions.
There's a little bit mistake in
the reasoning he made.
I want to repeat his question,
change it a little bit so maybe
he'll deny what this is what he
was saying.
But I believe what he just said
is what really happens in a lot
of regulation is they come in
and they change the prices.
They tax a good,
they prevent people from
trading so much so the price
changes.
They subsidize something.
Something happens so that you
get different prices,
and of course at those
different prices you get a
different allocation.
That's all true so far.
And then he said because
they're at different prices you
can't compare the original
equilibrium allocation to the
new equilibrium allocation.
Well, that's where he
shortchanged this proof,
this proof says however you get
to a new allocation (X^(i)-hat,
Y^(i)-hat), maybe it's because
the government has intervened
and changed all the prices and
done a bunch of other stuff,
but in the end after all that
intervention the government is
going to get you to a new
allocation (X^(i)-hat,
Y^(i)-hat), and that new
allocation can't be better than
the original one.
So that's the force of the
argument.
No matter what the government
does in the end the upshot is a
new allocation (X^(i)-hat,
Y^(i)-hat).
We don't have to think about
[how]
it got there.
That's where it got and
according to this argument it
can't be better.
So the argument is correct and
elegant.
There must be something missing
to the argument,
some assumption you don't
really believe if you doubt the
argument.
Yes?
Student: What if you
want an allocation that's better
for one party even at the
expense of the other party?
Prof: What if you want
an allocation?
Student: It's socially
desirable to have an allocation
that's better for one party even
if that comes at the expense of
another party.
Prof: So one argument
you could say is that it may be
in the equilibrium that A--so
who's better off here?
You notice that this
equilibrium A ends up with more
of everything than B does.
So you could say this
equilibrium is not very socially
desirable because A ends up with
more of everything than B does
or at least as much of
everything as B does,
and that seems unjust and
unfair and so we don't like the
allocation,
and so maybe we should move
something from A to B.
So that's an argument on the
basis of justice.
It says we can find juster
allocations that are somehow
socially more desirable,
but this argument of Pareto
Efficiency is about efficiency.
Maybe you could hurt A to help
B because that serves your
desire for fairness,
but that doesn't say anything
about how efficient the
allocation is.
It's still true that the
original allocation was
efficient in the sense you
couldn't make anyone better off.
So the economists would say in
order to hurt A and help B what
you should do is take some of
A's endowment away from him and
give it to her and then let them
trade to a new competitive
equilibrium where she began with
more than him.
And so the just thing to do is
to rearrange the resources at
the beginning and still let
people trade to a final
allocation.
So that's an argument from
fairness, but it doesn't
interfere, it doesn't contradict
the economic argument that fair
or unfair it's still efficient.
We've done as well as we could
making everyone as happy as we
can.
Maybe we can hurt someone and
help someone else but we can't
help everyone at the same time,
whereas most regulation the
argument in favor of regulation
is you're helping everybody by
regulating,
and this says you can't ever do
that.
So what's missing?
What's some of the assumptions?
This should be an elementary
question for you.
Yes?
Student: Is it violating
one of the three assumptions
that >
, the market theory?
Prof: No,
it's got all those assumptions
so there's something about the
model that's too narrow and this
should be easy.
You're going to tell me obvious
things where it's too narrow,
so I'm going to just say where
we're going.
You're supposed to be telling
me now obvious ways this is too
narrow.
I'm going to say,
"You're right.
You're right.
You're right,
but finance is different.
We don't have to worry about
those problems supposedly."
So go ahead back there, you.
Student: Externalities.
Prof: So one critical
shortcoming of this argument is
that there are externalities.
Suppose that X is cigarettes,
and A buying and smoking more
cigarettes makes B sick.
So that's not part of this.
Why is that not part of this?
Because B's utility depends
only on what B's consuming,
not what A's doing.
So there's no place in this
model.
It's too narrow to include
externalities,
so it doesn't capture the fact
that he,
by smoking, might make her sick
by smoking so many cigarettes
and that's not in here.
And if you put the idea that
B's utility, her utility might
depend on what he's doing and
not what she's doing the theorem
won't be true.
So there's a reason to tax
pollution, and to tax cigarettes
and all those things because of
externalities.
So that's a fundamental problem.
Yes?
Student: It's also
assuming that all of our
indifference curves are aligned
in the same shape.
Prof: Well,
we're assuming diminishing
marginal utility,
but each person has a different
indifference curve,
so yes.
We assume that they are all
curved away from the origin,
so we assume diminishing
marginal utility.
But I think that I'm almost
prepared to believe,
diminishing marginal utility.
It's not literally true.
Moving from one ticket to two
tickets may be a huge gain in
utility because now you can
bring your friend along.
Getting one ticket might not be
worth much because you don't
want to go alone.
Getting the second one may add
a huge amount of utility.
That's an increasing marginal
utility, but eventually after
you've got enough tickets it's
going to be diminishing marginal
utility.
So I believe on the whole that
diminishing marginal utility is
not such a bad assumption,
but this clearly relies on
that, so you're right but I
don't think that's the critical
problem.
What else is there?
Yes?
Student: Credit markets.
Prof: What?
Student: Credit.
Prof: Credit markets,
now we're starting to talk a
little bit about finance,
so just hold that thought for
one second.
Anything else you can think of
besides externalities that's
terrible for--so let me
transition this way.
So of course people notice
externalities.
Another kind of regulation is
perfect competition.
We assumed everyone took the
prices as given.
There was no monopolist setting
the price and refusing to
bargain with people and stuff
like that.
So regulation could come about
in order to enforce the
competitive equilibrium to allow
for perfect competition,
so we assumed that already.
That's one place for
regulation, and a second place
is because of these
externalities.
So for 50 to 100 years
everybody has accepted those two
arguments.
Clearly there's a place for
regulating free markets,
ensuring free markets and
stopping trusts and monopolies,
and for stopping externalities.
But then people said finance is
different.
There aren't any externalities.
You're just trading stocks and
bonds.
There's no pollution.
Nobody's going to get sick
because someone else has a stock
or a bond.
Some people might be jealous
but we're not really going to
take that into account.
We don't want to honor those
kinds of feelings of jealousy.
So the argument seemed to be
when you get to finance you
don't have to worry about
externalities,
and yes you have to worry about
perfect competition but once
you've got perfect competition
that's the end of the story.
So the rest of the course now
is going to be,
if you forget about
externalities because you forget
about pollution because we're
trading pieces of paper,
they're not polluting anything,
why shouldn't the financial
markets be efficient?
Why doesn't this argument apply
to the financial markets,
and one of the critical
financial markets is the credit
market.
So can you understand the
credit market on just these
terms and therefore argue that
the market's efficient?
So we're going to spend a large
part of the course talking about
that.
So unless you had some
particular point to raise now,
I'm going to just use your
comment as a good introduction
to the next part of the course.
So far there's nothing that
seems to directly involve
finance in what we've been
talking about.
So where does the finance come
in?
So Irving Fisher was the person
who created the first really
general equilibrium model of
finance.
So he was a Yale undergraduate.
He was a superstar Yale
undergraduate.
He graduated first in his class
from Yale.
He was a math major.
He decided that he wanted to
build a financial equilibrium
model.
There were no economists there
at his time.
We're talking,
in the late 1800s,
and so he went to Gibbs,
the famous physicist,
one of America's most famous
physicists at the time and said,
"Can you advise an
economics PhD?"
And Gibbs said,
"Well, if it's
mathematical enough,
it has a model and something,
yes I can do it."
And so Fisher's PhD
dissertation was basically
reinventing this general
equilibrium model that I've just
described and then making a
machine to calculate equilibrium
with water and pumps and water
seeking its own level and
solving for equilibrium.
And we had this machine up
until the 1970s in the Cowles
Foundation when it got stolen.
Some engineer named Sreenivasan
about ten years ago was ready to
rebuild the machine--
because we have the
dissertation where it explains
very carefully how Fisher built
his machine,
and he was going to rebuild it.
And then he was offered
ElBaradei's job.
ElBaradei is the guy,
the nuclear inspector who goes
to Iraq and says they're
building nuclear stuff or
they're not building this.
Anyway, so he was offered that
job, and so he left Yale and
then decided not to take the job
after all.
So we've still got ElBaradei in
the job.
But anyway, he left Yale and so
we never got the machine built.
He was a great guy.
Anyway, so Fisher after writing
his dissertation stayed at Yale
as an assistant professor and he
got tenure.
He became the most famous
economist probably in the
country for a while.
He invented finance,
as I'm about to tell you,
and in a way this model of
finance I'm about to present
which was in retrospect clearly
the most interesting model of
finance of its time,
and he was a financial
economist.
He also was an entrepreneur,
so you'll see later that he
started his own company.
It was a proto-computer company
called Remington and he managed
to make $10 million dollars for
his company in the early 1900s.
And he was a friend of
Roosevelt's and he kept advising
Roosevelt during the Depression
to print more money.
He said, "Print more money.
Print more money.
Print more money,"
and the Yale Library has all
these letters he sent to
Roosevelt.
It also has Roosevelt's
responses where you can tell
that Roosevelt is paying no
attention to him,
but Fisher's ego seemed to be
so big.
Roosevelt says,
"I'm very glad that the
good professor has made such
worthy recommendations and we'll
certainly take them
seriously."
And then Fisher writes back and
says, "I'm glad you're
going to follow what I
suggested."
So anyway, Fisher,
convinced that the economy was
going to turn around,
poured all his money into this
computer company Remington.
The company in the great stock
market crash nearly went
bankrupt and was leveraged.
So he had to go to his wife who
was very wealthy and borrow her
money, and they lost that money.
Then he went to her parents and
borrowed all their money and
lost that money.
And finally he had lost
everything of his money,
his wife's money and his wife's
parents' money and they were
about to take his house from
him,
foreclose on his house,
and so Yale was forced to buy
his house for him so he could
continue to teach.
So he set a bad precedent for
economists at Yale because
whenever any economist at Yale
has financial advice to give,
someone always quotes Irving
Fisher's 1929 line that the
economy had reached a
permanently high plateau.
But anyway, despite all that
his theories are well worth
studying.
He was famous for a few other
things.
Shiller is clearly trying to
imitate Fisher.
Fisher wrote a huge number of
books, 50 books about
everything.
So he got tuberculosis and he
survived and he wrote a series
of books on good living and good
health and how to combat
tuberculosis.
So he said you had to exercise,
you had to get fresh air,
and these were huge
bestsellers.
Then he said that drinking was
a terrible thing.
So he did an experiment in
class where he would have his
students do pushups,
then he'd give them all a
martini.
Then he'd count how many
pushups they could do.
Then he'd give them a second
martini and count how many
pushups they could do.
And he found that there was a
10% reduction for each martini.
And so he said that
prohibition--since the average
business person had two drinks
at lunch--that prohibition would
increase output by 20%.
And so he was one of the
leading proponents of
prohibition.
So after the stock market crash
he helped form the Cowles
Foundation.
So Cowles, who was a Yale
undergraduate,
had run a very famous macro
forecasting company in the
1920s.
And in 1929 the stock market
crashed.
There were a whole series of
these.
They sent newsletters.
The same kind of stuff they do
now.
He, unlike all the others,
after the fact realized that he
hadn't anticipated anything
about the crash,
much like nobody anticipated it
now.
And he was so embarrassed he
went and collected,
not only his old
recommendations themselves,
but all his competitors' and so
he published a famous paper in
which he argued that economists
had no idea what they were
talking about,
in fact that they were frauds.
And so he went to his old
economist Irving Fisher at Yale
and said,
"Look, I just believe that
economics without mathematics
has no meaning.
I want to start a mathematical
wing of economics and I've got a
lot of money."
His family owned The
Chicago Tribune and
The Seattle Times and a
whole bunch of other newspapers
and there was a famous fashion
model in the family,
Fleur Cowles and stuff like
that.
So anyway, so with Cowles'
money Fisher started the
Econometric Society which is the
most famous mathematical society
in economics,
Econometrica,
which is the most famous
journal in economics,
and the Cowles Foundation
which--they started off in
Colorado Springs because Fisher
said,
"Oh, the weather's so good
there everyone will want to go
there and it's good for
them."
So nobody would go there so
they had to move it to Chicago
where the Tribune was
and it was in Chicago from 1930
to 1955,
and then in 1955 it moved to
Yale.
And since then the Cowles
Foundation has been at Yale,
and you'll hear a lot more
about it later.
But anyway, so Cowles
[correction: Fisher]
with that background he set out
to figure out how to turn
economics--
in fact he invented economics,
this model of equilibrium to
study finance,
but so far we don't have any
finance in the model.
So how can you put it in?
Well, what is missing?
What do I need to put in the
model in order to turn it into
finance?
What would you say is missing?
How would you turn this into
finance?
What other key thing--yes?
Student: You need some
element of time.
Prof: So the first
thing--of course you may have
read ahead in the notes,
but that's a brilliant insight
if it's yours.
You need time in the model.
So far we just had apples and
oranges or something being
traded.
So the first thing is Fisher
said you need to put time in the
model.
What else is critically missing
in this model,
one other thing,
the major other thing?
Yeah?
Student: Risk.
Prof: What?
Prof: Well, that's good.
There's risk.
That's missing entirely.
So Fisher actually couldn't
figure out how to put that in
the model, but we're going to
get to that.
That's very good.
What else is missing?
Yeah?
Student: Impatience.
Prof: Fisher,
you'll see, had something to
say about time and impatience
that people always care more
about the present than the
future.
But what other fundamental
thing about--what is finance all
about?
When you think about finance
what do you think about?
Student: Savings or
credit rates.
Prof: So you think about
credit, as she said,
credit, interest rates,
and what else?
Student: Return.
Prof: Return,
that's quite related to that.
So all this has to go in the
model, but what fundamental
object when you think--the first
thing you think about finance
what do you think of?
Yes?
Student: Money.
Prof: Money,
so that's not what I had in
mind, but I'm glad you think
about money.
He's right.
That is what most people think
about, so money.
So in this course we're not
going to provide a theory of
money.
So Fisher did provide this
theory of money and that's what
he was talking to Roosevelt
about all the time.
We're going to talk about
inflation and stuff like that,
but we're not going to explain
where the inflation comes from.
So inflation is going to very
important, but we're not going
to talk about a theory of money.
So what else is missing,
something really basic though?
Yes?
Student: Institutions.
Prof: So there are no
banks and things like that,
institutions.
And still something.
Come on what's the...
Student: Loaning.
Prof: What?
Student: Loaning funds.
Prof: Loaning funds,
well somebody said credit.
That's sort of loaning funds
and interest rates.
Student: Collateral.
Prof: Collateral,
that's something.
I'm going to add that.
Thank you.
What a brilliant idea.
What basic thing?
Come on.
Yes?
Student: Wealth.
Prof: Wealth,
that's in the model.
Where's wealth?
It's already there.
So when you take your endowment
and you multiply it by the
prices in your budget set that's
your wealth.
So we've got wealth.
Student: Capital.
Prof: Capital,
so capital--and what is
capital?
What do you mean by capital?
If it's money,
I already told you that's not
quite going to be there.
Student: Contract.
Prof: Contract,
so we're getting there.
Student: Assets.
Prof: Assets,
so assets--that's the main
thing so I'm going to write it
over here, assets.
After all finance is a lot
about the stock market,
bond markets,
mortgage markets.
Those are all assets that you
buy that pay dividends later.
So assets are things that pay
dividends at a later time.
That's the critical thing
that's missing.
And when we talk about finance
we want to know,
what should the value of the
stock market be?
How much should a mortgage be
worth?
So those are the things we have
to add.
Now, how are we going to add
them?
It sounds like you might have
to just totally redo the theory
and start from scratch and do
something totally different.
How horrible that would be.
It would mean I also wasted
three lectures.
So Fisher said,
"You don't really have to
change very much at all."
So he said, "Number one,
time."
How do you put time in the
model?
Simply think of Y as the same
good as X but one period later.
So Fisher said,
"Time isn't such a big
deal.
We've already got two goods.
These crazy marginalists before
me they had good X,
which was interesting,
and this very boring good Y and
so it's not so clear how you can
have time and everything in the
model,
but I've already got two
interesting goods,
X and Y.
They're both entering with the
same symmetric properties.
Neither one of them seems more
interesting or more important
than the other one,
so in fact maybe they're the
same good.
It's just--X and Y is the same
good, it's one comes one period
later."
Now next class,
we're going to talk about
you're not going to value them
the same amount.
The utility for X and Y won't
be the same.
So here A obviously thinks more
of X than he does of Y,
and by the way,
B, she also thinks more of X
than she does about Y.
So why is that?
Well, if Y is the same as X but
a year later--people are
impatient.
So the reason why A might like
X better than Y and B also is
not because they're different
goods, but because they're
impatient.
So we're going to come to that
later.
So we can have the idea that
they're two different time
periods in the economy simply by
change of notation and not
introducing anything new at all.
Well, what about assets?
So I'm going to come back to
that in the next class.
What about assets?
How can you introduce assets in
to the economy?
Well, Fisher says,
"What is the essence of an
asset?
The essence of an asset is that
it's something that you hold
today because later it's going
to deliver you money or goods or
something."
And we're not going to talk
about money so we're imagining
these are all real assets.
So they're going to deliver
goods in the future.
So the definition of an asset
is an asset, remember,
we have to make it
mathematical,
so Fisher started this society
to make economics mathematical.
So an asset is literally
something that delivers goods in
the future.
So an asset is defined by its
payoffs, D_X and
D_Y.
So we can call that asset
alpha, an asset alpha is defined
by its payoffs,
D_X and
D_Y.
So it's going to pay a certain
amount of X and a certain amount
of Y.
That's all there is.
Now, we're going to ask,
do people actually know what
the payoff of Y's going to be?
If Y's in the future that means
it hasn't happened yet.
Do we really know what Y's
going to be?
And so maybe we know less about
one asset and more about another
asset, so maybe one asset is
riskier than another asset.
So someone said risk,
obviously that's going to be a
very fundamental question.
But before we come to risk,
if we don't have any risk yet,
because Fisher didn't know how
to put it in and we're going to
start with his model where
there's no risk,
then if there's just today and
tomorrow and everybody's
rational,
everybody, since there's no
uncertainty,
everybody wants to be able to
anticipate exactly what the
dividend's going to be.
So the asset is no different
from what its dividend is going
to be.
Maybe it's paying something
today and also it's going to pay
something tomorrow,
so assets are defined by their
dividends, nothing more than
that.
So the model now becomes a
model where we have the W^(I)
and then we have the goods as
before,
the endowments of the goods,
but we've added a new thing
which is we've added the assets
D alpha X and D alpha Y.
So the alpha's over all the
assets, and we have to add
everybody's ownership of the
assets to begin with.
So we have to have theta.
I'm going to call it theta bar
alpha, theta bar i alpha.
So how much of asset alpha does
i own?
So that's the economy that
we're going to start with.
So we've made the model a bit
more complicated.
We started where we did before
with utilities and endowments of
goods.
Now we're adding assets which
payoff more goods,
and of course people begin
owning trees and stuff like
that.
So a tree is an asset.
It's going to pay apples later
on and various different people
own various different trees.
So to the old economy we add
something new.
And now Fisher's ingenious
insight was that if you think
about this,
which we will for a little
while, you'll be able to
discover that you can simplify
this economy back down to the
economy we began with.
So you can start talking about
assets and interest and all
kinds of others things using the
same analysis as before.
So with my last thought here,
what does interest have to do
with P_X over
P_Y?
What is P_X over
Suppose they're both apples.
So X is an apple today.
Y is an apple next year.
What is P_X over
P_Y?
It says how much an apple is
worth today relative to how much
an apple is worth tomorrow.
So this is going to turn out to
be 1 the real interest rate,
Fisher would call it.
Because if P_X is
more than P_Y,
let's say P_X is 20%
more than P_Y what it
means is by giving up one apple
today you can get 1.2 apples
tomorrow.
That's just what happens when
you put money in the bank.
You give up something today you
get exactly the same thing back
next period but more of it.
So you see just by having time
and the prices like we had
before you're going to see very
quickly how interest,
assets, everything is going to
start coming into play very
quickly.
So I didn't put the problem set
on the web yet because I wasn't
sure how far we'll get,
but I'll put it on in a couple
hours and we'll start again on
Thursday.